[Applause]
[Music]
rose
it's good to be home
slow
thank you thank you thank you please
this may go to my head
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you thank you you know as they say
in part small neighborhood in Scranton
you guys brung me the dance and you
really did and I just want you to know I
had permission to hug Loni anyway look
it's great to be with you for real
Loni the International president has
done such an incredible job along with
with Kannon Secretary General Mike
director of construction and maintenance
but before I begin I want to say
something to you all congratulations
they might I mean by that
congratulations because you guys are
leading the union of them back 19 to
2017 Baltimore gas electric 1418 new
brothers and sisters biggest in 125
years 2018 a land of gas and light 700
new brothers and sisters and the keeps
going on look we're coming back you are
coming back we need you back when I look
how's this crowd let me tell you what I
see I see my old neighborhood and
Claremont and Scranton
I see the backbone and know what that's
not hyperbole I see the backbone of the
nation
I see people not only are smart but
people with physical courage to do the
things your members have to do I see
people who risk their lives going up in
those bucket and trucks after raging
storms and sometimes during them working
around the clock to power communities
people take it for granted climbing up
that damn pole you risk your life
we used to understand that the
ironworkers back in Delaware guy named
Tommy shrank when they endorsed me as a
kid running for the Senate he used to go
in and I meant it sincerely I grew into
the hall and I'd say I can't get over
you guys I admire your courage 17
stories up walking a beam shooting a
rivet and people saying is what they do
worthwhile come on man I see the people
in this room who represent the people
and our part of the people who make
manufacturing go I see the people who
lead the way to safer and cleaner energy
an energy future that's going to be done
by repairing over a million miles of 2
million miles of leaky pipelines most of
it put back into 1960s I see people who
build a 21st century electric grid that
will not only power this nation's
economy but protect this nation from
foreign adversaries and the way they use
cyberspace and the rest to go after us I
see people have busted their necks their
whole lives to earn their pensions when
you retire you deserve every damn penny
of work for not a penny less I mean it I
mean it
[Applause]
I'm tired of
look
it's not right I see people like
millions people across this nation who
get up every single day go to work raise
their families pay their taxes volunteer
in their communities and make the
country work and all you're looking for
all you're looking for is be treated
fairly with respect with some dignity
because you matter look think about it
this way that's how I think about it not
a joke and we used to think about it how
my family and my neighborhood thought
about it there is no possibility any of
those guys woman making millions of
bucks on Wall Street doing good work
wherever they're doing and doing very
well they could not function without the
work you do literally it's impossible to
make the country function without what
you do and don't you forget it
don't you forget what you do we've
gotten so damn sophisticated we've
gotten so damn elitist just like I hope
you guys understand when that storm
comes and the storm sewers overflowing
some poor suckers out there cleaning it
you owe him or her Thanks
they make life work for us
and I hate the way things have changed
over the last 15 to 20 years folks let
me ask you a question how do we get to
the place where people who build bridges
repair our roofs keep our water systems
going teach our kids take care of our
sick parents our children run into
burning buildings rather than away from
grow our food build our cars pick up the
garbage off our streets ironworkers
still workers Boilermakers plumbers
electrical workers how the hell do we
get to the place where a lot of you
don't think the rest of the country sees
you or hears you or knows you maybe most
important respect you little respect you
for what you do I tell all my
sophisticated friends they said well
that's they know this respect what are
you talking I said you do a job you hope
if you do it well your college gonna say
good job it matters it matters how we
treat people it matters how we talk to
them you guys are like me I never walk
away from a table without thanking the
waiter not a joke that's how I was
raised my father was a white collar if
you listen to Brock you'd think he
climbed out of a coal mine with a lunch
bucket in his hand from Scranton
Joe Biden from gritty Scranton they
really resent that in Delaware but my
dad was a guy who literally taught us
not a joke he said every single person
not a joke
deserves to be treated with dignity I've
never once saw my father never once saw
my father where's he walking into the
pomp building and the CEO walked by to
say hi and say hi to the shoeshine guy I
never once saw my father not treat every
one of his employees he was a general
manager of a large car dealership I
never once some didn't see Bruce he
thought the worst thing that could
happen the worst sin of all was the
abuse of power economic power political
power said the cardinal sins for a man
to raise his hand a woman or a child but
my father insisted everybody be treated
respect hello how are you great job
Thanks
simple basic things that let people know
what they do matter their work matters
their job matters they matter
let me tell you something and this is
not a political statement as a statement
of fact this country was not built by
Wall Street bankers and CEOs and hedge
fund managers a lot of good people but
decent people it was built by the great
American middle class
the most significant economic
[Applause]
that's the American story a story of
ordinary people from the neighborhoods
you and I grew up in going out given
half a chance of doing extraordinary
things and how do you think we both a
great middle class I've been saying this
for forty five years unions that's a
fact
unions some politicians are afraid to
use the word union not me
unions built this new class
for real
I think we even forgot it I think we've
forgotten my grandpa Finnegan used to
say Joey your Union from belt buckle
eschew so he said it more colorfully
than that if you have any doubt that you
guys and women both the middle class
just think about it the sacrifices you
made all the dues you paid the picket
lines you've walked the negotiations you
sweated through all those sacrifices
they didn't just benefit you they
benefited every American worker now
here's the deal guys there's no one who
has done more including the political
system congressmen senators governors no
one who has done more for non-union
labor than unions it's just a fact
minimum wage overtime pay 40-hour a week
weekends off I could go on for the next
five minutes all those rights exist
because you and my family way back in
the days it's grant fought for those
things non you can non you workers have
rights because those sacrifices you've
made and here's the good news for the
last I'd say close to 20 years they kind
of forgot it I could have bought into
this new you know right-wing economic
theory that you know unions are greedy
the very people you gave those rights to
but now they're beginning to realize it
you know why
most of you probably notice on this most
Americans I spoke of the business school
Northwestern University with I don't
know three four or five hundred graduate
students out there and I think what I
said to them surprise
of 40% are about 40 million
hourly workers have to sign a
non-compete agreement to get a job used
to be he couldn't work for Jimmy John's
making sandwiches unless you agreed you
would not compete within X number of
miles for another job so you couldn't go
to McDonald's and get a 10 cent increase
in your wage literally not a joke not a
joke what's that all about nothing other
than suppressing wages for stockholders
reclassification that's one of the
things that Secretary of Labor and I
were very proud of having done they
turned it around in this administration
reclassifying hourly workers as
management the woman who stacking the
ragu spaghetti in the supermarket if she
controls the guy the woman with the
wagon to bring the spaghetti out and
pallets she's now a manager you know how
much that cost hourly workers ten
billion dollars ten billion dollars not
getting paid for overtime folks look
average Americans are realizing they've
been getting the shaft in the name of
using you
I said you remember may remember Lonnie
the afl-cio I said five years ago
actually now seven years ago the Chamber
of Commerce has declared war on Labour's
house it's been a constant unrelenting
war all for one reason drive down wages
and benefits to raise dock holders value
not a joke but people are trying to
fingers starting to figure it out even a
lot of Democrats myself included I
didn't realize all these new non-compete
agreements our only work an hourly
worker non-compete you know if you are a
hair grader your braid people's hair you
have to get a license to do something
like 400 hours of training in another
state to move in to be able to braid
hair I mean it's all much more careful
it's all about not helping the worker
you know one of the things I love about
the IBEW is this you get what my father
has always said well my father left
Scranton when Cole died he was a
salesperson no good jobs the community
was dying I remember him walking up the
stairs my Grandpop's house sitting down
to my bed I think it's the longest walk
any parent can make to tell their kid
honey you can't go back to the same
school we're losing the house honey we
can't live there anymore you're gonna go
home a little bit grandpa we're gonna
it's only gonna take about a year hey
all those kids you want to come up on
the stage and come up it's okay come on
up come on
[Applause]
any kids can come up so how you doing
[Applause]
by the way guys
nothing artificial about if we don't win
if you know when you got a problem if
you win we win their futures but you
realize 54% of the American people think
their children will never reach the
standard of living they've reached
that's never happened before 54% and you
guys can sit in the edge or what if you
by the way he gave me permission to
touch him
[Applause]
I'm sorry to take so long guys but
everyone knows I like kids better people
but look my father when we move down to
down to claim on every time someone
would there be a recession like the
neighborhood you guys grew up in
somebody in the family lose a job or get
laid off maybe temporary but you know a
neighbor my dad you say Joey had jobs
about a lot more than a paycheck
it's about your dignity it's about
respect
it's about your place in the community
it's about being the look your kid in
the eye and say honey it's gonna be okay
and meaning think about it that's what a
jobs about it's so much more than a
paycheck a lot of people can't do that
today
so I said they don't believe that their
children are gonna be in the same
position they were they feel hopeless
they feel left out
fears crept into so many places around
this country so many times in our past
the worst among us act like in the past
are preying on those fears to divide us
why are you not to have a job why again
a low pay job it's the other it's the
other is that immigrant it's that black
guy it's that divide us divide us it's
an ugly extremism is on the rise in this
country we saw it most vividly in
Charlottesville on Klansmen and white
supremacist and neo-nazis came out of
fields crazed faces illuminated by
torches and bulging veins baring the
fangs of racism chanting the literally
the same anti-semitic pile the same
anti-semitic baoshan in the streets of
Nuremberg and Berlin in the 30s Amin
pettiness has overtaken our politics the
last decade sometimes it's things like
she sees if we can't govern ourselves
because I don't talk to one of them
anymore we barely talked to one
my whole career I've been able to get a
lot of things done I know I'm being
criticized by some on the far left that
I have actually think we should work
with Republicans but how do you get
something done
look folks this is not who we are this
is not the America we've known I mean
growing up but we have to remember what
it is that makes this nation so special
that's our core values it's what we
believe it's the American creed it
sounds corny we hold these truths
self-evident that all men are created
equal endowed by their creator with
certain inalienable rights as I said it
sounds corny but it's who we are
we've never fully lived up to it -
Jefferson's words but we've never before
walked away from them just walked away
from them I believe there's something
the columnist david brooks conservative
columnist sometimes calls an invisible
moral fabric he talks about the whole of
the nation together it's made up of
basic values the values that define us
honesty decency dignity respect giving
everyone a fair shot leaving nobody
behind giving hate no safe harbor and
leading by the power of our example not
just the example of our power that's why
the rest of the world has followed us we
are the shining hill as Reagan said a
shining city on the hill standing as a
beacon for the world but most
importantly we used to always understand
as Americans that were part of something
bigger than just us something bigger
than us that's who we are that's what
we've been that's who your parents were
your grandparents were these are the
values that made us the most respectful
and successful nation in the history of
the world not I Park hyperbole but look
how our view now you know we used to
used to be a basic bargain in America
you guys know it better than anybody it
said that if you're a part of building
the success of an enterprise you've got
to share in the benefits you've got to
share in the profits not now if an
enterprise
they sit hard it used to be everybody
took a hit the CEO the managers
the hourly workers but that part has
been broken now the only people of
benefit when a company does well or the
CEOs of the shareholders the people at
the top
I said Republicans have adopted the
conservative economist Milton Friedman's
dicta in the late 80s when he said a
corporation only has one responsibility
to its shareholders that's an economic
theory only to its shareholders not as
employees not to the community in which
it resides not to anybody but to
shareholders that's why you see these
tens of billions of dollars of buyback
of stock rather than reinvestment in
training and expansion since when is
that how we've run I have a cartoon in
my office the president used to always
come in and try to jokingly turn around
some of the New Yorker I still have it
in my office at Penn it's a picture of a
great big rotund guy from New York
magazine in a black turtleneck black
mask and a black beret sitting at the
end of a table like this the other end
of the table is an interrogator not the
other side the other end and there's a
great big burlap bag in the middle with
a money dollar sign on it and he's
looking at the interrogator to say I'm
sorry how was ice to mow how was I
supposed to know he was a job creator
you know since when did my dad who sold
all those GM products the guy's the
assembly line in devil who made those
products the mechanics have kept them
running since when did they not
contribute to the success of General
Motors it used to be as I said everybody
took a hit but now the only people get
hurt when a company hits a rough patch
of the workers two one-way street
I couldn't remain silent after General
Motors because I was the guy that was
given blame and credit for bailing out
being the loudest voice
we're bailing out General Motors an
iconic industry because I knew a
capability of American labor an American
labor the UIGEA but took a big kick to
get that done the first year back
General Motors made eight billion
dollars in profit in eighteen they made
eight billion dollars in profit
just a few years above after being
bailed out by all of you the American
taxpayer the CEO good woman CEO and top
executive the shareholders they did
incredibly well then the market turned
on four of their products maybe five GM
hit a rough patch so what happens they
close plants layoff 17,000 and UAW
workers announced they're gonna build
new facilities in Mexico and the GM
salary the head of General Motors goes
some twenty two point nine million a
year to twenty one nine that year alone
they made a hundred and nine I was one
hundred ninety four thousand dollars I
mean million dollars in in a tax break
they could have given every one of those
17,000 people laid off a ten thousand
dollar severance to give him a chance to
go somewhere they could have come back
and built those facilities of a new
electric car facilities in the United
States
[Applause]
but guys now it's every single cent you
say where is the social responsibility
what's wrong it's economically wrong and
it's morally wrong sometimes I think
President Trump is a tragedy in two acts
the first tragedy is that he treats and
poses everyday opposes everyday the core
values and beliefs of our nation the
things that go to our very democracy the
way he talks to people who ain't
characterizes them a guy who's the head
of the intelligent he calls him a pencil
neck I mean what in the hell is
happening our children are listening
second tragedy is he's so consumed with
personal grievances so obsessed with the
past but for three years now America has
been focused on the past not the future
well this president wages war on Twitter
and insults his opponent's attacks our
most important institutions the courts
the press to Congress inflames our
nation's oldest wounds of racism and
hate the rest of the world's passes by
whether it's China has now focusing on
5g or the rest of the world's embrace of
the Paris climate Accords look around
these countries are waiting no one's
waiting we better wake up
this country can't afford more years of
a president looking to settle personal
scores this country can't afford four
more years of a president lacked in the
past and grudges
we've got to get moving you guys know
better than anybody else you know the
21st century electrical grid can mean
America a great deal of America both in
terms of our economy and our national
security
you know the skills and job training
that are needed to handle that new grid
you know the kind of good-paying jobs
are great you know these are jobs of the
future whether it's working with
community colleges or job training
programs apprentice programs you know
how to get it done some things the same
thing goes across the board from
repairing and replacing those pipelines
who are putting the ground in the 60s a
couple million miles of it protect our
environment prepare us for climate
change it will create a whole lot of
good Union paying jobs if we do it it's
good for the middle class this is a
win-win situation the kind of jobs you
can raise a family on you know one one
of the great things you've done as
unions the making commitment to
diversity opening your doors including
everyone because what's true of unions
is true of America you're stronger we're
stronger when everyone's in on the deal
and you're proof of something that I
couldn't believe more strongly that as
we rebuild this middle class which has
been clobbered this time everyone comes
along black white Latino when men women
young old everyone we can do this it's
time to put our petty politics aside
it's time to start talking moving on
again politics politics it's in politics
there are opponents not our enemies you
know you had to get something done
because I've been part of getting things
done my whole career it's time for
America to start thinking big again for
God's sake this is the United States of
America it starts with a complete
overhaul of our nation's education we
have to start educating our kids sooner
we know so much more now every single
University and expert in the world
acknowledges that our kids get to
kindergarten or first grade but at that
time much of the brain is already
developed we need even more focus on
them in early education we have to face
up to the fact
12 years of education that's no longer
enough community college should be free
and we can afford it guys we can afford
it not a joke we don't to punish anybody
we can increase from 6 to 9 million
qualified people in community colleges
increasing the GDP by 2/10 of 1% a year
by eliminating just one of the one
trillion six hundred and forty billion
dollars of tax loopholes
it's called stepped-up basis you go out
and you make a big profit you're about
to go cash it in and make it pay a
capital gains tax and you get hit by a
truck you leave it to your son or
daughter good people they pay no tax
it's not an inheritance tax with tax
dude twelve seconds earlier at 17
billion dollars we are out of one
trillion six hundred plus billion
dollars it cost six billion dollars a
year to put everyone in the Community
College is qualified and that loophole
is 17 billion dollars you can take the
other 11 and reduce the deficit for
God's sake no one gets hurt no one gets
hurt
look folks we need an invest in job
training apprenticeship programs what
you do not only you know not only after
high school post high school but in high
school look around the country now when
we grew up
you could learn whether or not you liked
working with your hands you had shop you
had automotive guns you had a look they
don't exist in ninety percent of the
schools anymore what tells them matter
with us I did a study for the president
the jobs of the future we need for
example fifty-seven thousand more
plumbers seventy seven thousand illicit
goes on and you can make a decent wage
we should work to generate a consensus
Democrats and Republican know one
another if I know your husband or your
wife and you're a senator or congressman
and I know they're at breast cancer or I
know that you have a son or daughter
with a opioid addiction I know you just
lost your brother or sister it's hard to
dislike you I know you I make a personal
connection make a personal connection
and we can work together to compromise
but we don't even know one another what
happens what happens we attack each
other we attack each other based on
motive you're in the pocket of unions by
and you're in the pocket of big this
you're in the pocket of that hard to get
to yes and a compromise when you can't
even talk to one another
Democrats and Republicans can do better
look if we were building America today
from scratch we wouldn't just have a
twelve year education system the reason
why we led the world beginning in the
beginning of 20th century is because the
only nation in the world that had
universal 12 years of public education
that's what built this country don't you
what you built
so folks my wife Jill who's a community
college professor says the best she said
any country that out-educates us it's
gonna out-compete us it's just that
simple
it's that basic not only just mean high
school I don't I don't mean college I
mean in trades I mean in all the new
important technologies we have to master
that don't require college means but
require considerable knowledge we need
to take the next step to rebuild our
healthcare system the Affordable Care
Act was a big step
you guys have fought for and been able
to guarantee health care for your your
employees your members we need to build
on it what we can't do is blow it up and
cause 22 million people the Barack and I
were able to put on health care give
them peace of mind I remember my dad
when he went from one company another
lost his health insurance my mom said he
stared the ceiling and I just worried
what happens what happens if I get sick
what happens when my wife gets it we
lose everything it's peace of mind if
you remember when we passed the
Affordable Care Act President Obama I
said something in fact this is a big
deal
I swear to God I turned around this way
whispered in his right ear and I swear
somebody had to read my lips because it
wasn't hot anyway thank God my mom
wasn't around I'd be dead but look it
was a big deal
Obamacare is how we finally protected
people with pre-existing conditions
Obamacare is how we made it possible for
kids to stay in their parents policies
until they were 26 and so much more
the folks every day I worked alongside
the president's vice president but I was
never more proud to have participate in
anything other than passing that bill
and as you all know better than anyone
we need a massive commitment to
rebuilding our infrastructure
Republicans used to support
infrastructure what happened theory
canal was built by Republican governors
for God's sake and we can do it by
leveraging public money and private
investment but we can't wait we can't
have a 21st century economy in a 19th
century infrastructure we need to face
the facts that climate changes are
coming and it's here no amount of
burying our heads in the sand is going
to change that look at what just
happened to the US strategist US
strategic Strategic Command in Nebraska
because of the flooding of the rivers
out there in Nebraska seriously impacted
on our nuclear deterrence flooded out
our base in the United States of America
the Strategic Air Command was rendered
in a very precarious position because of
climate change it's not only a threat
it's an incredible opportunity by moving
to clean energy by setting higher fuel
standards for our cars by limiting
emissions from our power plant by
fortifying our cities in our coastlines
by facing up to just how many military
bases here in the United States and
abroad in the world are subject
rising tides low-lying installations we
have to prepare but it will create jobs
make us stronger and one last thing we
need big goals to inspire this nation
for me that means ending cancer as we
know it and we can do it for too many
people in this nation far too many
people in this room you have gone
through her going through what my family
went through when we lost my beau my son
cancer is brutal unforgiving and no
family ever has to go through that again
as my goal will not be too soon ending
cancers no it is a worthy national goal
and it's going to take a president to do
it it's within our power or making
enormous pressure you know why because
we're forcing these guys to work with
another again Doc's don't play well in
the sandbox together they're wonderful
work like hell but sharing data is not
something that has been available till
now when I finished the moonshot and
administration 21 heads of cancer
hospitals and five Nobel laureates and
the number of people came in said they
want me to set up a Biden cancer
initiative I said I don't I've read
everything I can about cancer and its
cures and what needs to be done but I
said I'm no expert they said I said why
me should you do two things well you can
convene people and you can shame them I
thought that's a hell of a thing
but folks I can honestly say I'm more
optimistic today than when I got elected
as a 29 year old kid not just about what
we can do to cure cancer but about
America America's in a better position
I'll end with this then we've ever been
in our entire career if we just get up
off our feet our backside stand up
remember who the hell we are
we've the largest economy in the history
of the world we have the most powerful
military in all of history we're the
most innovative entrepreneurs in the
world we have more great research
universities in America than all the
rest of the world combined as my wife
would say Google it with the most agile
venture capitalists we have most
productive workers in the world that's a
fact three times that's a fact three
times of productive as workers in Asia
we're virtually energy independent
something no one thought of before folks
there's no reason why we can't own the
21st century there's no reason why we
can't we just have to get out of our way
remember who the hell we are folks with
you and your brothers and sisters in the
movement remember who we are that this
is the United States of America there's
nothing we are incapable of doing
nothing so let's get the hell up and get
it done thank you
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]